you know what happens when people like
Dr Leanna Nguyen show up on CNN and they
freak everybody out without having any
information right or no not without
having any information with
disinformation right misinformation and
they lie about all this [ __ ] they get a
whole bunch of other people who know
nothing about nothing often Hollywood
actors and actresses to say crazy things
uh we thought this would be a nice way
of of tying this whole thing together
this is a piece on uh I think it's on
e-entertainment Channel or something or
Hollywood extra one of these nonsensical
things uh here's Jennifer Aniston back
in August of 2021 because I get most of
my vaccine information from Jennifer
Aniston and the whole cast of Friends I
really decided my whole thing I just
went back and I watched Friends and I
thought what would these people do
during a time of pandemic but here's
Jennifer Aniston back in August of 2021
and the woman would not even have you as
a friend if you were unvaxxed Jennifer
Aniston is doubling down on cutting
non-vaccinated people out of her life
amid the covid-19 pandemic it's
something that is a part of our world
now and it does it's not going away the
52 year old actress received criticism
earlier this week after her in-style
magazine interview dropped in which she
revealed she's cut several people out of
her Inner Circle who opted to not get
the kova 19 vaccine what you resist
persists Oprah Daly shared a post to
Instagram about Jen's recent interview
and the comment section was divided to
say the least and Jen's original
statement to in style she spoke out
against quote anti-vaxxers or people she
feels quote don't listen to facts she
told the mag quote I've just lost a few
people in my weekly routine who have
refused or did not disclose whether or
not they had been vaccinated and it was
unfortunate I feel it's your moral and
and professional obligation to inform
since we're not all potted up and being
tested every single day
at some level
I have a little Sympathy for the people
like Jennifer Addison right these NPC
type people these people who believe
whatever the machine says and that's why
I'm linking it to the lyanna Wen thing
it's like if you watched CNN for the
last couple years and you didn't pay
attention to Alternative sources of news
you would start cutting people out of
your life for not being vaxxed right you
would be thinking all of the wrong
things because of people like Leanna Wen
but it's so interesting how the media
like they're trying to make her a hero
she's sort of a hero back then for
cutting people out of her life because
they got vaxxed but what would be the
reverse version of that be you think
they would ever now that we know that
the vaccines don't work that there's all
sorts of vaccine injuries that covet is
just going to kind of be here like
anything else and people will get sick
and you should do whatever seems right
for you I don't know if you have a
sniffles have some tea you know would
you think they would do a story on a
Hollywood celebrity who's like you know
what I've decided not to get vacced and
I've cut out all the vaxxed people from
my life because they're brainless and
they're just you know little cogs in a
machine and I don't like them very much
and actually they do seem more sick Than
unvaccinated People you think that that
E entertainment Channel or whatever the
hell that was you think they do a story
on that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]